buenas tardes el presidente pedro
castillo ha firmado que se destrabarán
proyectos de inversión por más de 2 mil
millones de dólares que se encuentran
obstaculizados en el sector transportes
y comunicaciones se cobrarán deudas a
las empresas por más de 7 mil millones
de dólares para invertirlos en proyectos
de desarrollo social se fortalecerá a
los docentes con una bonificación
especial se aumentará las pensiones a
los jubilados y se respaldará a la
población frente al alza de alimentos
pero muchos congresistas no quedaron
satisfechos con el anuncio de pédro
casio porque señalaron que todavía
existe una agenda pendiente en temas
como seguridad empleo pobreza educación
y salud en un perú que tiene una
inflación que borre a del 9 por ciento y
los niveles de pobreza sobre el 30 por
ciento si precisamente hablamos de un
hemiciclo dividido en torno a la figura
del presidente como ha sido recibido el
discurso de pedro castillo como ha sido
el ambiente durante este día
le cuento que el discurso del presidente
pedro casi no ha durado una hora y 50
minutos durante su mensaje varios
congresistas le dieron la espalda y
otros se retiraron en señal de protesta
pero la finalización del discurso de
castillo tuvo momentos sagrados porque
muchos congresistas le gritaban que
renuncia y otros lo llamaban corrupto en
realidad los ánimos se
incentivaron aún más cuando pedro casi o
por concluir le pidió al parlamento que
trabaje los 45 proyectos de ley que él
ha presentado y les pidió que los
acompañe en una lucha contra la
corrupción y si bien castillo dijo en el
parlamento peruano que se someterá a la
justicia para esclarecer que las
acusaciones que se le imputan el
parlamento terminó pues por hacerle este
bullying y casi yo no tuvo más remedio
que retirarse al terminar su discurso y
fue rodeado por un fuerte cordón de
seguridad que lo acompañó hasta el
palacio de gobierno